we're told della wants to make a
one-sample Z interval to estimate what
proportion of her community members
favor a tax increase for more local
school funding
she wants her margin of error to be no
more than plus or minus 2% at the 95%
confidence level what is the smallest
sample size required to obtain the
desired margin of error so let's just
remind ourselves what the confidence
interval will look like and what part of
it is the margin of error and then we
can think about what is her sample size
that she would need so she wants to
estimate the true population proportion
that favorite acts increase she doesn't
know what this is so she is going to
take a sample size of size N and in fact
this question is all about what n does
she need in order to have the desired
margin of error
well whatever sample she takes there
she's going to calculate a sample
proportion and then the confidence
interval that she's going to construct
is going to be that sample proportion
plus or minus critical value and this
critical value is based on the
confidence level we'll talk about that
in a second what Z star what critical
value would correspond to a 95%
confidence level x and then you would
have times the standard error of her
statistic and so in this case it would
be the square root would be the standard
error of her sample proportion which is
the sample proportion times 1 minus the
sample proportion all of that over her
sample size now she wants the margin of
error to be no more than 2% so the
margin of error is this part right over
here so this part right over there she
wants to be no more than 2% has to be
less than or equal to 2% that green
colors is kind of too shocking it's
unpleasant all right less than or equal
to 2% right over here so how do we how
do we figure that out well the first
thing let's just make sure we
incorporate the 95% confidence level so
we could look at a z table remember 95%
confidence level that means if we have a
normal distribution here if we have a
normal distribution here 95%
confidence level means the number of
standard deviations we need to go above
and beyond this in order to capture 95%
of the area right over here so this
would be two and a half percent that is
unshaded at the top right over there and
then this would be two and a half
percent right over here and we could
look up in a Z table and if you were to
look up in a Z table you wouldn't not
look up ninety-five percent you would
look up the percentage that would leave
two and a half percent unshaded at the
top so you would actually look up ninety
seven point five percent but it's good
to know in general that at a 95%
confidence level you're looking at a
critical value of 1.96 and that's just
something good to know we could of
course look it up on a Z table so this
is 1.96 and so this is going to be 1.96
right over here but what about P hat we
don't know what P hat is until we
actually take the sample but this whole
question is how large of a sample should
we take well remember we want this stuff
right over here that I'm now circling or
squaring in this less less bright color
this this blue color we want this thing
to be less than or equal to two percent
this is our margin of error and so what
we could do is we could pick a sample
proportion we don't know if that's
what's going to be that maximizes this
right over here because if we maximize
this we know that we're essentially
figuring out the largest thing that this
could end up being and then then we'll
be safe so the P hat the maximum P hat
and so if you want to maximize P hat
times 1 minus P hat you could do some
trial and error here this is a fairly
simple quadratic it's actually going to
be P hat is 0.5 and I want to be I want
to emphasize we don't know she didn't
even perform the the sample yet she
didn't even take the random sample and
calculate the sample proportion but we
want to figure out what end to take and
so to be safe she says okay well what
sample proportion would maximize my
margin of error and so let me just
assume that and then let me calculate it
so let me set up an inequality here we
want 1.96
that's our critical value times the
square root of we're just going to
assume 0.5 for our sample proportion
of although of course we don't know what
it is yet until we actually take the
sample so that's our sample proportion
that's one minus our sample proportion
all of that over N needs to be less than
or equal to two percent we don't want
our margin of error to be any larger
than two percent and let me just write
this as a decimal zero point zero two
and now we just have to do a little bit
of algebra
to calculate this so let's see how we
could do this
so this could be re-written as we could
divide both sides by one point nine six
one point nine six one over one point
nine six and so this would be equal to
on the left hand side we'd have the
square root of all of this but that's
the same thing as the square root of 0.5
times zero point five so that just be
zero point five over the square root of
n needs to be less than or equal to
lecture let me write it this way this is
the same thing as two over 100 so two
over 100 times one over one point nine
six needs to be less than or equal to 2
over 196 let me scroll down a little bit
this is fancier algebra than we
typically do in statistics or at least
an introductory statistics class all
right so see we could take the
reciprocal of both sides we could say
the square root of n over 0.5 and 196
over a 2 let's see what's 196 divided by
2 that is going to be 98 so this would
be 98 and so if we take the reciprocal
of both sides then you're gonna swap the
inequality so it's going to be greater
than or equal to let's see I could
multiply both sides of this by 0.5 so
0.5 that's what my I said 0.5 but my
fingers wrote down 0.4 it's C 0.5 and so
there we get the square root of n needs
to be greater than or equal to 49 or n
needs to be greater than or equal to 49
squared and what's 49 squared well you
know 50 squared is twenty-five hundred
so you know it's going to be close to
that so you can already make a pretty
good estimate that it's going to be d
but if you want to multiply it out we
can
49 times 49 9 times 9 is 81 9 times 4 is
36 Plus 8 is 44 4 times 9 36 4 times 4
is 16 plus 3 we have 19 and then you add
all of that together and you indeed do
get so that's 10 and so this is a 4 teen
you do indeed get 2,401 so that's the
minimum sample size that Delos should
take if she genuinely wanted her margin
of error to be no more than 2% now it
might turn out that her margin of error
when she actually takes the sample of
size 2,401 it if her sample proportion
is less than 0.5 or greater than 0.5
well then she's going to be in a
situation where our margin of error
might be less than this but she just
wanted to be no more than that another
important thing to appreciate is it just
the math all worked out very nicely just
now where I got our n to be actually a
whole number but if I got 2,400 and 1.5
then you would have to round up to the
nearest whole number because you can't
have a your sample size is always going
to be a whole number value so I will
leave you there